aquí dibujé una función arbitraria lo
que intentaremos hacer en este vídeo es
aproximar la función con un polinomio al
cual cada vez le pondremos más y más
sumandos para esto vamos a necesitar
suponer algunas cosas vamos a suponer
que f se puede evaluar en cero pero
además de esto vamos a suponer que éste
se puede derivar repetidamente es decir
que existe en la primera la segunda la
tercera derivada y que todas esas las
podemos evaluar en x igual a 0 es decir
estamos suponiendo que sabemos quiénes
df de 0 quien es f prima de 0 también
sabemos quién es
efe doble prima de 0 también conocemos
efe
le pondré 3 lo mejor lo voy a poner efe
triple prima de 0 y así sucesivamente
entonces vamos a pensar cómo podemos
aproximar que suceda esto con las
derivadas usando polinomios que van
aumentando en longitud vamos a empezar
con algo muy sencillo un polinomio
constante es decir un polinomio de grado
0 al parecer aquí tenemos muy poca
flexibilidad pues sólo podemos dar un
valor hay que aprovecharlo muy bien
bueno al menos intentamos que el
polinomio evaluada en cero coincida con
efe evaluada en cero es decir vamos a
ponerle que p de cero donde p es el
polinomio que vamos a proponer vamos a
ponerle que p de cero queremos que sea
igual a efe de cero si queremos lograr
esto con un polinomio constante o sea un
polinomio de grado cero pues estamos
forzados a tomar el polinomio que está
dado por p de x igual a efe de 0 vamos
al dibujo a ver cómo se ve quedaría más
o menos una recta horizontal paralela al
eje x sale y entonces tú me puedes decir
estás aquí es una aproximación súper
chafa únicamente pasa por este punto
algunos cuantos más por aquí se parecen
muy poquito y entonces yo te respondería
a ver intenta hacer algo mejor fíjate
que al menos logramos hacer que nuestra
aproximación coincidiera con efe en x
igual a cero esto es lo mejor que
podemos hacer con una constante ahora
déjame hacer una aclaración
efe de cero podría no parecer constante
pero recuerda que ya tenemos una f dada
y ya está evaluado en un punto dado
entonces aquí hay un número ahora es el
número lo pusimos de este lado tomamos
el polinomio igual a efe de 0 y eso nos
da una línea horizontal a la altura f de
0 bueno esto de aquí parece que aún no
está suficientemente padre pongamos más
restricciones además de pedir que puede
cero sea igual f de cero vamos a pedir
también que p es que p prima de 0
también sea igual a efe prima de 0 es
decir lo voy a poner con otro color a
ver también queremos que esto de aquí no
es un nuevo color ahora si queremos que
prima de 0 es decir la primera derivada
de nuestro polinomio cuando lo evaluamos
en cero sea igual a efe prima
entonces no queremos perder esta
condición de aquí arriba simplemente
estamos añadiendo algo más déjame
proponer p de x igual a efe de cero es
decir tomamos el pd x anterior pero
ahora vamos a añadir un nuevo sumando
vamos a ponerle más f prima de 0 x x
vamos a ver qué sucede con este
polinomio a ver si usamos p de x como
nuestro nuevo polinomio que sucede
quienes p de 0 a ver de 0 es igual a
pues es igual a efe de 0 y luego vamos a
sumar f prima de 0 x x pero cuando x
vale cero entonces nos va a quedar cero
verdad si ponemos x igual a cero se
cancela entonces simplemente nos queda
puede ser igual a efe de cero y eso está
súper padre palomita eso es lo que
queremos va ahora vamos a la derivada la
derivada de px es prima de x y es igual
a werder y vemos esto aquí hay una
constante entonces su deriva de 0 y de
este lado tenemos f prima de 0 por x
pues simplemente nos queda el
coeficiente o sea f prima de 0
ahora evaluamos en x igual a 0 entonces
vamos a ponerle prima de 0 y entonces
eso de ahí es igual a pues la derivada
del polinomio evaluado en 0 está un
poquito raro verdad porque tenemos pues
un p prima y un f prima y así pero si
siempre tenemos muy claro quién es la
variable va a estar fácil aquí está muy
fácil verdad que prima es simplemente f
prima de 0 esta derivada es constante
pues aquí tenemos un número éste número
viene desde el principio verdad cuando
asumimos que f tenía derivada y que la
podíamos evaluar en 0 esto nos da acá
abajo una constante de este modo si p
prima de x siempre se fue prima de 0
entonces claramente prime evaluada en 0
también va a ser igual a efe prima de 0
pero lo que está padre de este nuevo
polinomio este de aquí que acabamos de
inventarnos con un término constante y
un término lineal lo que está padre de
ese polinomio es que ahora coincide con
efe en x igual a 0 verdad aquí pero no
sólo eso sino que también tiene la
primera derivada igual para x igual a 0
es decir también tiene la misma
pendiente entonces bueno vamos a hacer
un dibujo entonces el dibujo nuevo se
vería
más o menos así es decir es una línea
que tiene la misma pendiente que f en x
igual a 0 y además pasa por el punto
cero
efe de cero eso está muy bien vamos
avanzando le pero de todas formas pues
no está como que súper padre esta
aproximación aquí todavía tenemos
simplemente una línea pero la f todavía
está un poco curva vamos a mejorar
nuestra aproximación con la segunda
derivada para lograr que tengan la misma
segunda derivada pero conservando que
tengan la misma primer derivada y el
mismo valor en cero vamos a tener que
hacer algo un poco más interesante
déjame proponer una función más voy a
ponerle por aquí
pd déjame dejar primero antes claro que
este fue nuestro primer intento que este
de aquí fue nuestro segundo intento y
ahorita vamos a pasar al tercer intento
en este tercer intento el objetivo es
que el polinomio coincida con efe en
cero además que su primer derivada
coincida con la de f en zero y además
que su segunda derivada también coincida
con la défense ero entonces voy a
ponerle p de x iguala y lo primero va a
ser copiar esto lo del término anterior
entonces le voy a poner
efe de 0 + f prima de 0 por x es decir
esto de aquí y luego voy a sumar un
tercer término que voy a poner en verde
más más y aquí voy a poner un medio que
espero que luego se explique porque lo
estoy haciendo entonces más un medio de
fbi prima es decir la segunda derivada
de la función evaluada en 0 x x cuadrada
cuando evaluamos la segunda derivada nos
explicaremos por qué aquí está este un
medio pero vamos paso a paso vamos a
empezar con p de 0 a ver qué pasa con p
de 0 déjame ponerlo aquí abajo entonces
p de 0 es igual a pues a ver aquí
tenemos un f de 0 sumado con algo x 0 y
con otra cosa también por 0 así esos dos
sumando se cancelan y solamente nos
queda efe de cero eso va muy bien ahora
vamos con la derivada de px la voy a
escribir aquí a la derecha en amarillo
entonces pp prima de x es igual a haber
esta constante f de 0 tiene derivada 0 y
por tanto nos queda
efe
de 0 x un 1 y luego hay que sumar aquí
este 2 baja verdad porque estamos
derivando un x al cuadrado 2 por un
medio es un 1 entonces nos queda más f
doble prima de 0 x x es decir el 2 lo
multiplicamos y bajamos el exponente en
1 vale entonces creo que esto explica un
poquito porque pusimos el 2 lo que hace
es compensar el hecho de que la derivada
nos va a bajar un 2 y va a multiplicar
por ahí ciertas cositas verdad cuánto
vale prima de 0 haber prima de 0 es
igual a pues a ver aquí tenemos esto que
se hace cero y nos queda simplemente f
prima de 0 entonces es igual a efe prima
de 0 hasta ahí vamos muy bien hasta
ahorita nuestro polinomio de tercera
generación tiene todas las propiedades
de los primeros dos vamos a ver qué pasa
con la tercera derivada pero perdón con
la segunda derivada es decir p prima
digo de doble prima de x haber es la
derivada de esta constante que es cero y
luego la derivada de este término lineal
que ese doble prima de cero
esta de ahí es la segunda derivada ahora
cuál es la segunda derivada evaluada en
cero pues misma idea del argumento de
antes simplemente es la constante f
prima de cero baja eso está muy padre
verdad al agregar este término no sólo
logramos que pe de cero fuera igual a
efe de cero y además que prima de cero
fuera igual a efe prima de cero sino que
también logramos que p doble primer cero
sea igual a efe doble primer cero es
decir ya coincide el valor y las
primeras dos derivadas estoy aquí ya
parece como que pues nos va a aproximar
muy bien a efe verdad y más aún parece
ser que tenemos un patrón parece ser que
podemos ir aumentando términos para que
cada vez nos aproximemos más y más a las
derivadas que nosotros queremos es decir
a las derivadas de la función original
vamos a hacerlo en general si
quisiéramos seguir haciendo esto y
tuviéramos mucho tiempo entonces
tendríamos que hacer lo siguiente
tendríamos a ver lo voy a poner con otro
color más lo voy a poner con este rojo
entonces p de x la podemos proponer como
sigue lo primero es efe de 0 el primer
sumando de siempre
luego hay que poner un f prima de 0 x x
luego ya vimos que hay que sumar un f
doble prima evaluada en 0 x un medio de
x al cuadrado
simplemente reescribir esto un poquito
diferente y luego hay que sumar pues
ahora vámonos a la tercera tenemos que
poner f triple prima evaluada en cero y
luego hay que multiplicar por el un
medio que teníamos antes y luego un
tercio que vamos a necesitar 1 entre 2 x
3 x x al cubo a ver sigamos esto se está
poniendo interesante a lo mejor podemos
descubrir un patrón más entonces si
quisiéramos que las cuartas derivadas
coincidieran tendríamos que sumar f
prima prima prima prima aquí convendría
poner un 4 pero lo voy a dejar así
mientras evaluada en 0 x a ver esto
anterior lo voy a poner pero en orden
contrario y voy a poner un 4 4 x 3 x 2 y
eso de ahí x x a la aumentamos 1 x a la
cuarta puedes verificar lo por tu cuenta
si deriva este polinomio 4
y evaluarse en cero te aseguro que vas a
obtener la cuarta derivada de f evaluada
en cero esto podríamos seguirlo si
quisiéramos continuar podríamos sumar y
sumar términos y el enésimo término se
vería como la enésima derivada de f
evaluada en cero multiplicada por x sala
n dividida entre n factorial fíjate que
eso es lo mismo verdad aquí tenemos un 4
por 3 por 2 que es 4 factorial bueno nos
falta un 14 por 3 por 2 por 1 pero el 1
no tenemos por que escribirlo aquí
tenemos un 3 factorial verdad tenemos un
dos por tres pero es lo mismo que 3 por
2 por x 1
otra vez el 1 no hay que ponerlo aquí
tenemos un 2 factorial 1 2 por 1 aquí
abajo tenemos bueno nada pero es lo
mismo que poner un 1 factorial porque
eso es un 1 y aquí pues tenemos esto
dividido entre 0 factorial que también
es igual a 1 recuerda por definición
cuando seguimos esta serie ir sumando y
sumando términos hasta tener una
infinidad se dice que hemos encontrado
la serie de mclaren de f
serie de mac loring este es un resultado
de aproximación bien poderoso después
vamos a ver algunos resultados muy
padres que salen a partir de esto en la
gráfica lo que está pasando es lo
siguiente en el primer paso tenemos una
línea horizontal en el segundo paso
coincide la función en f de 0 y además
coincide la derivada entonces también
tenemos una recta pero ahora esa recta
tiene la misma pendiente que f en cero
cuando agregamos un segundo grado
entonces tenemos una parábola y esa se
va aproximando a efe para el tercer
grado se ve más o menos así para cuarto
grado se empieza a pegar cada vez más a
efe
y conforme sumamos más y más términos la
gráfica se empieza a parecer más y más a
la de efe sobre todo cerca de x igual a
0 en teoría si sumamos una infinidad de
estos términos y claro dijo en teoría
porque pues todavía no lo he demostrado
pero en teoría si sumáramos una
infinidad de estos términos entonces
todas las derivadas coincidirían y
acabaría pasando que las gráficas de
ambas funciones se verían igualitas
en el siguiente vídeo voy a hacer esto
pero con algunas funciones muy concisas
pues para fijar ideas como comentario
final la serie de más gloria inés el
caso particular de cuando centramos en 0
la serie de taylor en la serie de taylor
podemos centrar la aproximación donde
queramos pero vamos con calma nos
enfocaremos en mclaren